will Kanye West be the one to reunite
Caitlyn Jenner and the Kardashians oh
that's wild the rapper tweeted a
screenshot from a text combo he had with
the former Olympian in the exchange
Caitlyn shared a photo of her rumored
girlfriend Sophia Hutchins rocking a
Yeezy ensemble along with the message
quote Sophia loved the first set of
looks your team left and went all Yeezy
for her travel outfit today we love your
looks
thanks again Kanye's response so awesome
you're welcome the text between the two
are significant given that the
transgender activist has been on the
outs with the Kardashian family ever
since her book secrets of my life was
released last year in the biography
Caitlyn makes some claims against her
ex-wife Kris Jenner that the family says
are just not true
I feel sorry for her that this is how
she has her memories the famous family
discussed the ongoing feud with Caitlyn
and whether or not to invite her to
their annual Christmas party during
Sunday's episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians nobody that's coming would
even know how to respond to her because
of all the things - although what why
are we worried about anyone else it's
the night even if she doesn't come it's
nice time she would come you don't feel
bad for my dad not being in public I'm
with mom on this she shouldn't have to
invite anyone she doesn't want to spend
her time I think at Mom's house it's
whoever she wants
[Music]
[Applause]